[Music]
I'm Martinique Lewis diversity and
travel consults and travel content
creator and black travel
Enthusiast as the saying goes you don't
know where you're going if you don't
know where you've been so where have we
been well all
over but the story of how black people
travel in America runs
deep that's why I'm so excited to take
you with me on a trip to someone of the
most historic and iconic cities that
shaped Black Culture as we know it these
are the spaces and places that connected
and strengthen the black
community the places that supported some
of the biggest names and icons of those
times carry your greenbook with you you
may need it was the motto the Negro
motorist greenbook help keep
African-Americans safe when traveling
during the Jim Crow era that's what told
you about hotels restaurants barber
shops and so many other things that you
needed as an African-American when
traveling from state to state so come
along with me as I experience these
green rots of travel across
[Music]
America travel today looks a lot
different than it did 80 years ago and
it probably looks most different for the
black Trav in
America our Mobility has been police
since before the creation of
automobiles so we are keenly aware that
freedom of travel hasn't come to us so
freely but like most things in our lives
we made a way out of
nowhere and from the fight of the
ancestors before us we are reaping the
fruits of their labor
today
oh it wasn't easy but it was
necessary since the rise of the black
travel movement African-Americans spend
$19.6 billion annually on travel that's
no chump change I want to retrace the
roots of travel in this country to get a
true feel of the history they left for
us to discover and one thing about black
Travelers during those times is baby
they were going to dress from head to
toe and that's exactly what you'll see
me doing when traveling from place to
place paying homage to Black designers
everywhere I'm starting my cross country
track in New York City and you can't
travel to NYC without coming to Harlem
the place where it all
started and the place where Victor and
Alma Green's negro motorist greenbook
was
realized Victor Hugo green a poster
worker used a grass Roots method to get
his travel guide into
circulation tapping his fellow mailman
to help reach a broader public he also
distributed VIA mail order black
businesses and media campaigns with the
help ofo gas station known as Exxon
Mobile
today his partnership with ESO allowed
him to distribute the greenbook at
various gas stations making it front and
center for a key audience talk about
genius marketing
[Music]
a constant in the green book was the
Harlem YMCA the heart of New York
[Music]
City and if the Y is the heart then the
woman I'm about to meet is one of the
vessels helping to keep its story
alive Renown author and Scholar Dr
Gretchen saurin long before I was born
my parents had moved from North Carolina
to New Jersey as part of the Great
Migration and every summer we traveled
back to North Carolina to visit my
grandmother and that really got me
started when a colleague of mine handed
me a green book and said have you ever
seen this and I had never seen it even
though I didn't know anything about it
um it seemed to be my own story it
seemed to be about my own story and
that's how I wanted to figure out what
this was about for African-Americans
costing 25 cents the first edition of
this 15-page travel guide focused on New
York City businesses that welcomes
African-American customers an
ultramodern treasure Highway another
great new advance in traveling the
Nationwide Road
Network state byst state this guide
helped Travelers maneuver with dignity
and less
fear our parents didn't talk about it
they didn't want to scare
us they didn't want us to really know
how dangerous it was to go out on the
road and so they didn't talk about
it but there were lots of things that
were peculiar about the the travel that
we did in the late 50s and the'
60s we used to get up and we would drive
at night um we would drive in the dark
and I found out that that's what other
families were
doing you travel in the dark because
it's less light ly that you're going to
get stopped by the police they're less
likely to be able to see in the
car and then we would always carry all
of our food and you know we'd say we'd
like to stop at a hotel or let's stop at
a restaurant no we're going to carry our
food in the car and we're going to stop
by the side of the road and eat those
were things that African-Americans
devised to keep themselves
[Music]
safe
black people wanted to travel just like
other Americans they wanted to see the
country they wanted to educate their
children they wanted to see the national
parks they wanted to see the
sites I love how in your book you go
through the importance of the automobile
to the africanamerican family people
didn't necessarily want us on the trains
with them and they didn't want us on the
bus with them the importance of the
automobile is where our store starts if
you had to take the segregated bus or
you had to take the segregated
train you would do everything you could
to keep away from that
humiliation and it was humiliation right
people would yell at you you had to sit
in the back of the bus you had to sit on
the dirty train car the Negro car you
didn't want to do that and you certainly
didn't want that for your children but
if you could get some money together and
get an automobile Henry for ironically
makes that possible right because of
mass production automobiles are much
less
expensive and you can buy a car and you
can take your family
privately without
humiliation um in your very own personal
independent
space and that made a huge difference
for
families a huge difference indeed and
where did many of those families go
just like today New York City in the
1920s the Harlem Renaissance took shape
and attracted travelers from near and
far rolling right up to the birthplace
of the Negro motorist greenbook so
Harlem is really Victor greens and Elma
greens base you know they are on Linux
Avenue they're right at the heart of
Harlem right Harlem was originally a
white community that becomes blacker and
Blacker as African amans get get pushed
further and further north and in the
1920s you have African-Americans from
all over the country artists writers
moving to Harlem and you have this
incredible flowering of Black Culture
right you have
clubs you have
music you have
art you have poetry
right you have culture it's really a
mecca for black people
I counted one time there were 144 sites
in the green book wow in New York Harlem
today covers many city blocks and has
over 60 blackowned businesses everything
from restaurants and cafes to bars and
unique
shops once a predominantly Jewish and
Italian burrow Harlem began to shift to
a more black and Puerto Rican population
during the Great Migration of the early
20th century
this was a time when African-Americans
sought social and economic equality
laying the foundation for future
success the era known as the Harlem
Renaissance was a golden age of
African-American culture in the United
States and today I'm walking down one of
the most iconic blocks where these black
artists and literary Giants would meet
hang out and cultivate the image
[Music]
the history of this block may be unknown
to some but was palpable for Justine and
Juliet Masters who fell in love with
this location 9 years
ago when we were about to sign the leas
for the building we googled 580 St
Nicholas and it showed herina Anderson
Andrews who worked as a librarian on
135th Street at the shamberg
library and it showed her and her
friends on the roof of the building like
you know partying having a good time her
friends are Langston Hughes
wow soril
Hurston de boy you know Charles Johnson
like Heavy Hitters the cre circle of the
Renaissance the Caribbean British Fusion
restaurant The Edge opened its doors on
the historic block 8 years ago and what
a historic block it
is so in June of 2021 the uh dorren
Brook Square was given historical
landmark
[Music]
status Dorr Brook was a soldier one of
the first black soldiers fighting in
World War I I
believe under his regiment was the
Harlem Hell
Fighters so his building that he lived
in is two blocks down that way uh and
it's it's welld deserved cuz all these
buildings along Edgecomb Avenue are from
the era of the early harm
Renaissance um so they definitely have
that vibration so yeah it's it's it's
beautiful it's All About The Vibes and
with the rich history continuing to be
written here every day the new Vibes are
sure to
arise Harlem is a mecca for
African-American culture and experiences
and on this historic block Juliet and
Justine Masters are making sure you can
taste
it so when people typically come into
the edge what can they expect when they
step foot here they can expect great
service great food yeah and a good vibe
we hear that often everyone's like oh I
like the vibe in
here and then you know and our food is
really good our food is very
good I'm getting a little hungry can I
go try some of the things on the menu
absolutely let's go I fed my soul with
the rich history of this area and now my
stomach with this bomb meal my taste
buds are thoroughly Sav
this in real life is delicious even
though times change and history is often
forgotten I'm happy to see places like
the edge revive and pay homage to that
history and build on its
foundation food culture and lodging have
always been Staples of the travel
experience but if I was perusing these
streets 80 years ago my hotel choices
would have been limited would which
brings me back to the
YMCA so many people like Martin Luther
King came through here what was the
overall goal for the young men's
Christian Association or how we all know
it the YMCA the wise were there for
physical and emotional and spiritual
uplift and sadly they were they were
colored wise and they were white wise so
if you think about Travelers black
Travelers they needed places to stay and
even in New York there was segregation
you couldn't stay at the hotels downtown
and so the YMCA provided that haven that
safe haven where you could find a room
and a place to stay
overnight and right now we're sitting in
the mural room that now serves as a room
to help some of the kids who live in the
local neighborhood but this mural is so
important and can you talk about what
the mural means and why it is important
well Aaron Douglas is an incredibly
important artist in the Harlem
Renaissance and his mural represents
aspects of African-American
life and you can see the banjo an
important instrument brought by slaves
to this
country you can see enslaved people you
can see dancing you can see music and
you can see a slave cabin at the center
it does need a little bit of
conservation but it's absolutely
beautiful if not for Scholars like Dr
Sauron or extraordinary figures like
Victor and Alma green all of this
history could very well be a history
[Music]
forgotten Victor green made a difference
Alma green made a difference and
children should know that they can make
a difference too and that it's their
responsibility to continue to push this
country forward and to change
it
better
[Music]
I hate to say goodbye to New York but my
journey through the green book
beckons when Victor and Alma created the
green book in 1936 moving about our
great country with ease was difficult
for people who looked like
me during this time restrictive laws
known as the Jim Crow laws were
enacted these laws were collection of
state and local statutes that legalize
racial
segregation
and though these laws are more commonly
associated with the South a majority of
the states of the Union enforce
segregation either
legally or by mob
[Music]
rule so African American Travelers may
have found Freedom with the automobile
but that freedom needed to be carefully
planned out because there was
danger a danger known as Sundown
towns Sundown towns meant black
Travelers had to be out by
Sundown these towns were deliberately
designed to Encompass a majority white
population intentionally excluding
African-American citizens and other
people of color these were some of the
scariest places for African-American
Travelers and they didn't always know if
they were driving through a Sundown town
or whether or not they were welcome at
all this is part of the reason the green
book was
[Music]
created but as daunting as it was black
Travelers were not
deterred with the green book in hand
they pressed on to visit loved ones seek
opportunity and not least to enjoy
Blissful
[Music]
experiences traveling with my own green
book in hand I've just arrived in a city
known for its barbecue iconic Jazz scene
and the place credited as the home of
Negro League Baseball Kansas City
Missouri Kansas City has a unique
vibrancy and charm and it steeped in the
history of people who look like
me it's the same history that was being
written in the early 20th century that
Drew people here then and has brought me
back today and one of these are is that
captures the Lush history is 18th and
Vine a nationally recognized historic
African-American
District eventually morphing into a city
within a city 18th and Vine became a
landing spot for many African-American
migrants during the Great Migration it
was a place that African-Americans built
from the ground up and called
home and if there's one thing that makes
this place so special to me it's the
fact that in 1920 Kansas City gave birth
to the Negro
Leagues when eight independent black
baseball teams met in the P YMCA at a
time when two things were on the
rise baseball and
segregation so I'm here at one of the
most important places in American
baseball history The Negro League
Baseball Museum to talk to one of the
most knowledgeable people you'll ever
meet Mr Bob Kendrick thank you so much
for sitting down with me how did this
Museum go from one room to this 10,000
square ft it really is an amazing story
that in its own respect mimics the rise
of the Negro leag the sound of a ball
meeting a bat no one thought that the
Negro Leagues would ever succeed it's a
sport that appeals to all ages to all
groups and not only did it succeed it
would operate for 40 years and and it
literally changed the game and our
country and here comes this little fing
Museum in 1990 known as The Negro
Leagues baseball Museum born in a little
tiny one room office right across the
street from where we operate inside the
Lincoln building where it was situated
in that little one office had a
conference room table and guys like the
Museum's founder Buck O'Neil and other
local negro leagal who were still with
us at that time yeah you know it's sad
to say that they all passed on yeah but
they literally took turns paying the
monthly rent y to keep that little
office open and with it our hopes and
dreams of one day building a facility
that would pay rightful tribute to not
only one of the greatest chapters in
baseball history but what now thousands
of people from around the world learn
one of the greatest chapters in American
history I love that so the Negro
motorist green book was created between
the 30s and the 60s around the same time
as the Negro baseball leagues how
important was it for them to be able to
have a resource like that oh vitally
important because you're looking for
safe havens sanctuaries that would offer
you those basic services that you
couldn't get and then when you delve a
little deeper into the story of the
Negro Leagues we kind of learn that the
Negro Leagues were such a tremendous
Catalyst for those black businesses
success those segregated mandated
blackowned businesses which emerged to
meet the needs that weren't being
fulfilled because we couldn't patronize
those white
establishments and here was Negro
Leagues baseball bringing those
businesses a builtin
clientele so while the circumstances
were not ideal they had a resolve that
ultimately helped create something that
was so
special
something that was inherently
[Music]
ours that same spirit is alive and
healthy today all over the city
blackowned spaces have a knack for
preserving our past while nurturing the
future so you brought her
in case in point Ruby Jean Juicery which
combines nutritious food with family
roots and is named after the grandmother
of founder and Kansas City native Chris
good Ruby jeans it really started about
10 blocks or so that way okay uh my
grandmother she was a really really
pivotal person in my life the woman a
few words but you know when black
grandma speaks you listen you better
listen my grandma came from Vian
Oklahoma little bitty dot on the map you
look too fast you'll miss it um but she
brought from VI in the Kansas City this
love of Soulful cooking and the the part
that really kind of Set It Off course
was that soul food is not it's not this
lifestyle that you should live day in
and day out and that's the only way she
knew to cook that's the only way she
knew to provide for her family uh
unfortunately when my grandmother was 61
years old I was a 14-year-old kid she
got really sick really fast with type 2
diabetes she didn't really believe in
Healthcare and unfortunately that cost
her dearly and us as
well and so I carried that through life
you know want to show people like man my
my grandmothers were
[Music]
amazing fast forward um God gave me that
ability through Ruby James
CH and I love right here on your wall it
says health is freedom and that's so
important when we're speaking about
black community communities because we
know historically our communities are
food deserts but then there's a Chris
good who's from Kansas City and who says
I'm going to open up this Juicery in
honor of my grandmother literally in a
food desert this is the first ever
healthy business on the entire east side
of Kansas City in the history of this
city in the entire east side of Kansas
City when it first came to me I
questioned it m I said I know this place
30th in truce like will this work and so
when I grappled with that and I rested
on the idea I said you know what I got
to do this because if I don't do this it
may not ever
happen and sometimes all it takes is the
courage of one to change the course of
history much like Victor green and his
wife Alma did with the Negro motorist
green
book the green book is a testament to
the kind of America ordinary black
Travelers moved through not so long ago
and you'd want to believe that the
biggest Superstars and ball players of
that time fared better but they suffered
the same
injustices come spring and the old
refrain Take Me Out to the Ball Game
Echoes Across America from the Western
to the east baseball America favorite
pastime some of the best men to ever
play the game were
African-American they entertained the
masses but struggled to be seen as
equals by the white
[Music]
fans you have players who were arguably
the best baseball players who people
would come from far and wide whether
they're white or black to see them play
and while they were traveling to these
places they couldn't eat in a restaurant
they didn't have anywhere to stay and
really their challenges were for the
most part traveling the highways and
byways of this country the baseball
field was in essence their Sanctuary y
that's where they got a chance to do
what they do to put on a show and those
fans would ride into a town fill up the
ball party M and yet not be able to get
a meal from the same fans who had just
cheered them exactly or not have a place
to stay so they would indeed sleep on
the bus and eat their peanut butter and
crackers until they could get to a place
that would offer them basic Services it
would have been easy for them to quit to
say the hell with this you know because
it wasn't as if they were making a
boatload of money they were making a
decent living playing the game they
love the circumstances that dictated a
need for Negro Leagues are sorrowful but
not the Negro Leagues themselves The
Negro Leagues themselves are triumph
over that adversity and we need that
story I don't want the only side that
you see of me to be as the down triing
side of my experiences you need to see
my success stories CU very few folks can
relate to that down Triden side of my
journey seeking equality in this country
but you can relate to my success story
and so if you only see my struggles then
you never see the real me and I think
through the lens of these courageous
athletes they didn't know they were
making history they didn't care about
making history they just wanted to play
ball but the pride the passion the
perseverance the determination the
courage that they demonstrated in the
face of adversity yeah would not only
change this game but more importantly it
would change our
country you see resilience and
perseverance are in the DNA of the black
experience in America when obstacles are
put in our way we figure out how to come
out on the other side of achieving New
Heights we know that this is
historically the black neighborhood it's
the east side of truce which if anybody
knows anything about truce west side is
more white east side is more black and
in our neighborhoods the the mascots you
see is a white man on KFC a girl with
red hair on Wendy's but then you got
this black woman right you have this
black woman who's beautiful with gold
earrings red and that's what the babies
are seeing when they're how does that
make you feel um it you know it's
humbling uh I'm I'm grateful that God
gave me the foresight to be able to see
it to not only have the opportunity to
honor my grandmother and my family but
to honor all the other families out
there that exist the beauty about my
grandmother is that her story is a
universal
story there's a ruby Jean in your family
there's a ruby Jean in every single
family unit represented we have this
ability to tell a very black story that
touches every Walk of Life when these
doors are open it's not just black
people coming in here it's not just
white people coming in here there are no
boundaries for the people that come here
I love the vibe and so that's the thing
that we've been able to create here is
create truth and reality and rawness and
realness through our lens and just
sharing our story come in here feel like
you at Grandma's house get a hug get a
smile and feel this Vibe because we all
need
it and just like that my time in Kansas
City Missouri is
done the one word to describe my
experience in Kansas City as a whole is
full full with Good Eats full with a
richer knowledge of history and full of
gratitude next up I I travel to Denver
Colorado or as some may know it the
Harlem of the West to get a lay of the
land on its historic Five Points
district and what made it such a magnet
for black Travelers back then and the
businesses that are hoping to return it
to its former
glory Guided by the Negro motorist
greenbook I've traveled hundreds of
miles west and one mile
high Denver Colorado is home to the Five
Points District which in 2002 received a
well-deserved historical landmark status
and still Bears some signs of the
flourishing African-American community
that lived here Five Points was the
heart of African-American Commerce
during the days of
segregation and of all of my travels
this place is the nearest and dearest to
my heart because of my family connection
to
it my family includes the Butlers who
migrated from Maryland to Denver where
they met the
hoopers and through a special Union my
grandfather was
born the man in this mural is my
grandfather's uncle benny Hooper a
successful businessman and The
Unofficial mayor of Five Points who
poured his time energy and resources
into this once historically
African-American
neighborhood my great uncle was one of
the many African-Americans who helped
Quil the myth that the wild west was
inhabited by an entirely white
population and not only were the
businesses singing a glorious tune but
so were the many iconic musicians who
ushered in the Denver Jazz scene helping
the Five Points neighborhood earn a very
fitting
nickname I was lucky enough to catch
professor and author Dr Ronald Stevens
to fill us in on details of how Five
Points eventually became the Harlem of
the
[Music]
West talk about myig migration of
African-Americans to Denver why Denver
was so desirable for African-Americans
to come here after the Civil War and
during Reconstruction what a lot of
people don't understand was there was a
growing black middle class that's when
it was first emerging and of course uh
the first voluntary uh migration of
African-Americans was in 1877 to
Nicodemus Kansas the
Exodusters I don't know if you've ever
been Kansas but it's almost like right
in the middle of Kansas you know it's
burning hot they got here they would
promised that you know they'd be able to
build a community and which they did a
church Schoolhouse several homes but
there was a problem with water and so
some families left Nicodemus and they
continued West and some landed in Denver
Denver was founded in 1850 uh 1858 I
believe right and so as Denver was being
founded African-American are migrating
slowly and the numbers start to grow by
1900 so you think about you know the
entertainers but you also had black
middle class cuz the middle class could
afford to travel and many of them
previous to this were traveling by rail
first but by 1929 you got
African-Americans who have automobiles
especially the entertainers and the
musicians and they will get on the road
so between Kansas City Missouri and Los
Angeles right Denver was the major hub
for African-American music jazz in
particular and that's why it's called
the Harlem of the West Harlem of the
West absolutely and that was basically
because of the huge Jazz scene that was
here the huge Jazz scene and so you had
the musicians coming you had
African-Americans middle class that
lived here in Denver but you also had
African-Americans traveling to Denver to
see these shows and this is all
happening
just as Victor green publishes the green
book which was an idea that he had
pulled from the Jewish Community the
Jewish Community was using that for the
cat skills in New York they were using
that like in the late part of the 19th
century y well he got the idea of being
a poster worker right uh from that
African-Americans are resilient people a
lot of that history is hidden right a
lot of that history is
ignored but you have a growing
population of African-American
historians sociologists professors that
are doing research that want to rescue
black
history which is American history yes
wait say that again black history is
americ is American history and without
black history we can't talk about
American history but even American music
right the roots of American music is
black music right from spirituals to the
blues to Jazz to rock and roll all the
way to
hip-hop ah but we digress back to Five
Points I know Dr Stevens has a story or
two that might be missing from your
average history book back in the 1920s
there was a a Joseph Westbrook of
light-skinned in African-American who
could pass as white so 1920s there was a
large clue clut Clan here in Colorado
it was second to the kli CL in Indiana
Westbrook was able to infiltrate the
clus clan that had planned harm on the
Five Points community so he was able to
warn the black businesses cuz it was
thriving in Five
Points it's like they say success breeds
enemies especially for thriving black
communities in the
1920s but success also breed
success 100 years later Five Points is
still here from longtime Community
Staples to the New Kids on the Block hi
Miss the Five Points District in Denver
Colorado has a legacy of africanamerican
Excellence longtime business owners like
Franklin and Mela stiger take pride in
carrying that torch forward as the
neighborhood
changes
Frank and M May thank you so much for
allowing me to come in here today when
people talk about five points they
always say you have to come see the
stigers and they've been loving you guys
for the past 40 years correct I've been
here for 4 better uhhuh and I sered the
people
well and so over the past 40 years how
many people from the community did you
employ here at the barber shop about
three off and on you know and during my
time you had the natural and the Jerry
curl
uh-huh and that's what
brought the money in okay Miss May you
had a Jerry girl
yes did you have a Jerry C Alro that was
a natural okay that was your
natural but then too for the community
and with the projects being over on the
rapper ho the little kids that come in
and uh said uh Mr stiger can I sweep the
floor can I do this no for lunch money
and he used to always have one or two of
them you know come and help clean up the
shop and give them money and they would
take that money and that was their
school lunch money for the week one of
the kids uh turned out to be a doctor
wow and whenever he come to Colorado he
comes to the shop love I just love that
you guys are such a staple in this
community and you're still here here I'm
always looking for ways to support black
businesses but the stigers remind me
that it's not just about buying black
these small businesses are the
foundation of their communities creating
the opportunities role models and
healthy environments that for so much of
American History black people couldn't
find
elsewhere entrepreneurs in Five Points
like rysa Jones take that responsibility
seriously now tell me a little bit about
the name te's where exactly does that
come from my grandmother your
grandmother and we happened to be
drinking out of her teacups and her
plate okay and was her name teely her
her given name was Evelyn Jones okay and
you guys call her teely she was a wee
bitty little thing so somehow that
translated to teely gotcha so what was
that deciding factor to be here cuz our
presence was so diminished M the
presence of black people being people a
historically black
neighborhood was so diminished so Welton
Street is a historical Corridor cultural
historical
Corridor um like in most cities where we
live it's redlining it's segregation you
could perform you could entertain it
didn't matter how famous you were you
could go downtown to do those
performances you couldn't stay and you
couldn't stay m and I'm like no way I
that that's where I want to be I want a
place where we as africanamerican people
can see ourselves yeah so you have a
place of comfort and that's where my
grandmother ties in because I always
thought of her house of like it was good
food good company good conversation and
wisdom again and again family is the
inspiration for the business owners I've
talked to I wonder was ree's family
always so
entrepreneurial my dad had SNL
properties in Little Rock Arkansas on
Ninth Street he had the chat and chw
restaurant okay a liquor store and a
hotel and a hotel and a hotel in the in
the 30s during the Depression W and this
building was a hotel at one point also
this building was a hotel at one point
the greenbook also listed tourist homes
as an option for lodging which were
homes of ordinary citizens who extended
their hospitalities to families passing
through
town but in Five Points the hotels were
the district's soul in those days not
only for the necessity but also for
their buzzing
atmosphere the most famous is an
architectural Landmark the ronian first
built in 1912 the hotel hosted black
travelers to Denver and major players
from the American Jazz scene Dr Ronald
Stevens has the
scoop on the main floor that was the
jazz lounge and then you know the hotel
on the upper level floors but what was
unique is the number of entertainers the
ma major names that came through here
which is why Five Points got to nickname
the Harlem of the West
gotcha and many of those entertainers
they either performed Outdoors or at
some of the hotels downtown where they
couldn't stay
right and in between they would go back
to you know the
Ros and that's where they were
performing so it was a a dynamic spot it
lasted up until roughly around the 1950s
just as you know restricted uh coverage
was uh lessening and African-Americans
were able to move other places the
legendary ronian still stands today as a
beacon to those generations of black
Travelers
in fact Legends can be found all across
Denver's Five Points district and those
Legends Run Deep you always hear the
legend of your family and always say
Legend cuz you're trying to okay where
where's the fact yeah and where's and
where's where's the where's the fiction
right right right right what's actually
true right right literally last Friday
my
nephew pulls the Scrapbook out
and I'm like oh my gosh this matches the
legend with here's the fact to match I
love it and you know I had to take a
peek at Reese's history which as Dr
Steven said is really American history
oh my gosh and it's your own green
book it is truly I cannot believe that
they have preserved this this is
fantastic this book goes this is the
only way we know
to the 30s the 40s oh my so this is my
grandfather wow Samuel he was he was
Samuel Franklin Jones senior my dad was
Samuel Franklin Jones
Jr I love that your family has so much
history in a place like Little Rock that
also has so much history in terms of
segregation in terms of civil rights I
mean the Little Rock N all of that oh
this is the chatt and chw so this is
inside the chatt oh my gosh look how
well they were dressed
wo I know I'm look the hats the clothes
handsome wait a second CNC Hotel yes
Jones liquor store which we just saw the
chat and which we just saw and oh my
gosh okay we have to see if they're in
these Green books okay let's take a look
I hope they are I'll give you this one
do a little research I want to look okay
CNC Hotel so I would need to look under
Little Rock and this is the green book
from 195 4 and this one what do I have
here 1940 Edition yep established in 36
and the 1940
Edition so let's see if we can find
Little Rock what you're finding I found
CNC
wooo wait a minute CNC West Street West
nth all of his properties were on West
West nth street Oh my days yes your
family is in the green book is in the
green book woohoo and you're in the new
new green book my version wait wait wait
wait liquor store Jones 528 West 9
Street this is
so I don't even know what to say yeah
that's them and then it says please
mention the green book and patronizing
these these places this is fantastic it
is your family literally is part of
National History and the proof is Right
Here and Now tea leaves is also part of
National History
and you are the
proof wow
[Music]
phenomenal